falls du dich fragst was diese ultra
fluffigen Teigtaschen mit Puderzucker
und Backpulver zu tun haben ich verrate
es dir vor einigen Jahren wollte ich
einfach nur meine Schwiegermama mit den
fluffigsten Teigtaschen der Welt
beeindrucken also habe ich rum
experimentiert und dachte wie kann der
Teig noch fluffiger werden
seitdem gebe ich zu meinem Porter Teig
nicht nur frische Hefe sondern auch
Puderzucker statt Kristallzucker und
Backpulver das Ergebnis ist unglaublich
das Rezept habe ich vor Jahren mit euch
auf meinem YouTube-Kanal geteilt und
seitdem hat es eure Herzen erobert macht
dieses Rezept unbedingt mal nach und ich
bin mir sicher ihr werdet keinen anderen
Teigtaschen Teig mehr verwenden schreib
euch natürlich alle ganz genauen Zutaten
und die einzelnen Schritte auf damit die
Sie ganz einfach nachmachen können
diesmal habe ich eine richtig würzig
leckere kartoffelfüllung gemacht und
wenn ihr euch an diese einfachen
Schritte haltet dann bekommt ihr auch so
ein cooles und super beeindruckendes
Muster dahin macht's unbedingt nach und
falls Sie wissen möchte wie es
ausgegangen ist meine Schwiegermama war
sehr beeindruckt